All right, welcome to today's Zoom call. It is the 6th of April. My oldest daughter is birthday, so
so very happy day for me ready years ago. So let's get into some details. Remember to everybody that
first thing you should do if you have a question is to search for it because on our blog and on our
website we have lots of answered questions and pretty soon on our membership site hopefully next week
there's going to be more questions answered and actually on the membership site what I did is I put
a little question box that you could actually post your questions in there and I think wow,
that's a really good question. I might even just make a video on that question so you might make
videos out of the questions, especially if you think there's good questions for the video and
that's where you'll post your questions for the Zoom call. So instead of emailing the questions in
two cutters clinic at Gmail or two year liaison or two import cutters clinic just so they don't get
missed you could just put your questions in that box. So it's really nice little form. You can
fill out, you just log in to the membership site and you'll put the questions in that box.
In the meantime and even after that I always go to this little new dad magnifying glass on our website and
you could ask a question and you'll get a whole bunch of different pages where that question might
already be answered so that you don't have to wait for the Zoom call. Of course I love answering
questions on the Zoom call so but if you want to get to a question and answer faster that's a good thing.
My new book again is the seven phases of detoxification that's available as a free download.
That's that you need anything else to read but this may help some of your family members or friends
that maybe don't have cancer and it just talks about the why we my philosophy of detoxification
isn't just supporting your liver you have to support all the phases of detoxification. So that is a
term that I made up so there isn't anything else that you'll ever read about seven phases of
detox. You're only going to read about phase one phase two and maybe you'll read about phase three
detoxification that has to do with liver physiology. I point the rest of those terms but I think it's
really fitting that it helps convince them to understand detoxification so you can download it's not very
long book and it's a free download of the site. All right let's get to questions. My brother Bob
had his genetic review Zoom call and was and we asked Ann about red light sauna therapy. Could you
speak about red light sauna therapy. So sauna is obviously something that we're very big because the
idea of using a sauna is that you are taking pressure off of your liver. So if you go to sauna
the benefits of the sauna is that you're sweating in the sauna so you're using your skin as a major
organ of detoxification which it is. So by sweating you are helping getting rid of toxins and
poisons in your body and that can be extremely beneficial. So a sauna to increase your body temperature
just to a sweat is huge because it takes pressure off your liver. A sauna can also sometimes not always
depends on the sauna depends on the person can also raise core body temperature. Now there's
different studies that people do in saunas with different saunas and such can it raise but core
body temperature and the studies say yes but the truth is that every person is different and it may not
raise your core body temperature. So you can't make those promises with a sauna that's raising
core body temperature but it's still good for you to use a sauna if you're in there sweating. Now there's
other additions that many saunas come with different light therapy that can have benefits. So what's
the benefit of like red light therapy? So first of all red light therapy that there's many different
definitions of that. So there is laser therapy so there's the use of lasers for helping healing
but when we're talking about them putting different colored filters over lights and having that
be a therapy, it's more so dealing with a person's psychology maybe. I don't know really the physiological
benefits. I don't know how much that's been proven with different lights. I think it does. I know it has
a change in your frontal cortex because different lights, different colors can affect your frontal
cortex. And if you go on our blog again and you read or you do a search for parasympathetic, sympathetic
tone what are the ways that you would calm a person's sympathetic from a functional neurology perspective
is to use colored glasses. Like even using sunglasses, what's even better is like rose colored
sunglasses, mawvy colored sunglasses, have been proven to decrease sympathetic tone. So red light
therapy, there can be some benefits to just slowing your sympathetic. So your sympathetic nervous system
remembers your fight or flight mechanism, it is housed in the part of the brain called the
messence cephalon. So different colors, red rose colored mob can slow the messence cephalon down
and that can be hugely beneficial for anybody dealing with immune issues and immune countervise
and cancer, you try to stimulate parasympathetics. So any way that you could decrease sympathetic tone
can be beneficial to then increase parasympathetic tone. So that's where that would be beneficial,
but it would be great. The same person had histamine genes, so and recommended that he
don't eat lechdovers, but freeze individual meal size healthy to thaw them in their refrigerator
overnight. Could you please speak about this? So whatever we talk about histamine, it's not about
eliminating histamines because that is literally impossible. So all foods contain some histamines,
and the purpose really isn't even to eliminate all histamines if you if you could, that isn't even
necessary. So understand histamines are in a lot of different foods and a lot of foods have
higher sources of histamines than others. Foods that even have moderate or even low amounts of
histamines, the older the food is, the more histamines it will have in its contents. So that's the idea
that eat as many lechdover foods. But histamines are also made in your body. Your immune
risk part of your immune response is a histamine response. We make all these different cytokines,
chemokines, and histamines are in that classification, and they are an immune precursor and an immune
stimulant to deal with something in your body. That's why when you're exposed to pollen, you get a
histamine reaction. Now that histamine is made by your mass cells in your body, and then it's
cleared through a different gene called your HNMT gene that makes a DAO histamine enzyme that
breaks down histamine in the tissues and gets rid of it. But the idea of decreasing histamines in your
diet, especially if you have a lot of genes, the DAO genes, not the HNMT genes, you don't make if you
have defects in your DAO genes, you don't make a lot of the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine
in the gut. So by decreasing the amount of histamines you eat, it will decrease the amount of
histamine reaction in your gut that would require an excess production of DAO enzyme. And if you have
defects on those pathways, you don't make enough already. And so it can decrease the inflammation,
the overall inflammation of your gut. Again, it is not a perfect science because you can't get rid
of all histamines. You're just trying to reduce the load. So if you think of histamines as a bucket,
when you fill up the bucket too much it overflows and you could have a hyperhistamine reaction,
you just try to reduce the load. Here's an article from our blog, the low histamine diet,
high histamine food list. I have multiple articles about histamine in our blog because histamines
are a major issue, especially with COVID and the COVID vaccine, having mass cell issues
can kill people. So histamines are a player in that. They're not the only player in mass cell
activation issues, but they are a player in that. So anything you can do to reduce histamines
the better off it is. Other articles that talk about histamine and different cancers too. So
go to this little thing here again and search for histamines and you'll come up with this article
on histamines. Next question. We've read a lot and watched your blog videos about blocking EMFs.
I thought EMF radiates in all directions. So if so, how does the hedron block EMFs? Good question.
So the hedron is this little device that you stick on the back of your phone like this
and it can help with EMFs. Did you notice what I just said? It can help with EMFs. There is nothing
that is going to block EMFs altogether except putting your phone in a Faraday cage. So a Faraday cage
is just anything that completely blocks all electromagnetic function. So we have those little
sleeves that you can buy. I think there are 20 bucks on our web store. There are little soft
material sleeves and you can stick your phone in and you can fold it over and it will grow it up
and you literally will block all EMFs coming through your phone. But you will also block all usage of
your phone because the phone won't receive any data from it because it's completely blocked. So
so what are you going to do? You can't use your phone then. So but it's a good thing to put your
phone in that little Faraday sleeve because it will then block all EMFs. I mean, when you're at night
or when you're not using your phone or when you don't need to use your phone, some people put them
in their pockets and when they put their phone in the pocket, they just slip it right into the sleeve.
So they're not going to be able to receive any phone calls. They won't receive any text until you
take it off of that and it connects with the network again and it goes ping ping ping ping ping ping
and now you can always text or emails or phone missed calls. But that's the only way to give you
full protection. The heat run gives you some protection. I opinion better than the heat run is the
safe sleeve. So safe sleeve is the brand name of a phone case. I just got a new phone a couple weeks
ago and I'm waiting for them to come out with the size safe sleeve. We had ordered some
I had to check with Dustin to see if we got them in for the S21 or S22 and I think it's the S20
Galaxy S22 to do. So that is the best thing short of using Faraday cage. So you can still receive
phone calls and stuff but literally when you have it that in that in the safe sleeve which is just a
phone case but it looks kind of that looks kind of early 2000 Z because it's it's just kind of older
style. You have to have it that way if you're going to have protection. So that's even much better than
the heat run. So I will have a heat run and a safe sleeve. So for the for the money it gives you the
best protection or something like that. And understand with anything with EMFs nothing is going
to protect you fully. You're going to have an EMFs exposure and you just kind of try to reduce
that exposure as best as possible. Do you have anything on blood type diets? Is there anything to
that theory? These are two different questions. So the blood type diets was a book that was put out by
Dr. Amaro I think was to say years ago probably back in the 80s. And he used blood types to say that
the way we evolved was based upon the blood type we evolved from different why to go. Whatever
that that's why a type O could eat meat to the type A doesn't eat meat or whatever it is in a
type B should you know be a vegan or whatever I don't remember I read the book a long time ago when
it came out. Well I have major issues with it because I don't believe we evolved number one. So it
doesn't make any sense to me whatsoever in that way. Do I think though that some people do better
on a vegan diet and some people do better on a you know they have to eat meat three times a day in
order to keep their their blood B12 and their red blood cell content high enough and oxygen
oxygenation of red blood cells up yes I do but I don't think it has anything to do with what type
blood you have. So if it's like oh no man I'm a type A and it says I should be eating meat and boy I
have to eat meat I think that's just a coincidence I don't think it has to do with blood type that's
just my opinion. But I do know that there are people that do much better on different diets and there's
certainly food sensitivities that you have to stay away from what you need to deal with that. So I always
suggest you do a Cyrix test if you really want to know about food sensitivities and if you have food
antibodies that so it makes the most sense from a scientific perspective in my book is that do you have
circulated antibodies to that food or that peptide of that food that then every time you eat that
food you end up having an inflammatory reaction and it possibly constantly won't be an issue that's
how you should test for it not based on blood type. Next part of that question is also what
preparation do you recommend if I decide to follow through with mastectomy we'll make sure you
contact your liaison there are some things that we want to do with it is individualized based upon
the supplements that you're currently taking so make sure you contact your liaison if you want to make
a point with me through that too. Some of these questions are sent to people's liaison so I
says Ashley does Dr. Cutters know about royal bimbe ultrasound yes I do we heard it's better than
the right for sheet the lady said that she used the right for sheet her tumor grow she said it didn't
go deep enough well I would 100% agree with that lady if she was using most the right for sheets that
are on the market so most of them remember maybe you don't remember but a lot of interviews people
have asked me about the right for sheet and how I qualify the quality of a right for sheet and it the
quality of a right for sheet is based on number one if it doesn't have enough power to go through the
person's body it's completely worth us but that is literally you know paid out of 10 right for sheets
there's one right for sheet made in Canada where the guy is telling people that the right for sheet
goes out 30 feet you tested it because a friend that had one and tested it it goes out six inches
so these some of these companies will just outright lie to you it's very disturbing so to me the most the
best machines on the market are the true right and the GB 4000 as far as the power of put a
machine if you don't have enough power to get through a person's body then it's not going to do anything
so I would agree if this person was using you know some of the right for sheet out there it wasn't
to penetrate their body and it didn't help them so and then you know the second
quality of a right for sheet has to penetrate the body has to be programmable so if you can't put
in the frequencies that you want to use it's completely worth us has to be a user friendly
if that's where the GB 4000 falls into the flat because it's much more difficult to use it's much
more difficult to run around it's a big kind of clunky thing so it's and then lastly it has to
use a ball so a lot of right for sheets you're holding little things in your hands so it's really
electrical frequency it's not light frequency and there's benefits to that for different things you
can kill amoebas through that and things but you are not going to really kill kids or so
has to have those four qualities back to this the royal vibe I'm not going to diss any other equipment
out there but an ultrasound machine has very has a lot of efficacy for different things when I did a
lot of muscular skeletal issues I had an ultrasound machine in my office I always love
ultrasound it was really good for for cysts in in tendons it was really good for
other muscular skeletal injuries muscle endurance such because you're literally putting in these
through these sound waves and breaking up the tissue but to me to use ultrasound with cancer
it's to I just don't I just can't wrap my mind around the physiology I mean to me you could you
have the potential of spreading the cancer you don't want to break up the possibility that the body
is going to wall off this cancer and stop it from growing and then you're going to break it out
I just to me it doesn't make any sense why you use ultrasound for cancer I just don't understand that
can you use peabf and right machine at the same time absolutely yes so peabf is an electrical
frequency totally different wave like totally different spectrum than right like frequency so yes yes
yes I used to that all time so we could use both concurrently there's no harm in that order a little
bit of that too discomfort with somebody today was concerned about using right of course they
had they are too patient of ours yet they're concerned about using right but they had an implantable
device so when you have an implanted device like a defibrillator or something like that or one of
those blood sugar monitor things then you do have to be careful with the peabf
um right is not going to hurt any implantable device any electrical device you're not going to
have issues with the right you may with the peabf so you do have to be careful with it you can
technically still use peabf on your legs if you have a performer up at the or something like that
and you have a defibrillator you can still do it on your feet but you do it to be careful on the
intensity that you use if you certainly wouldn't do it near your heart if you don't have a pacemaker
or something you could do the peabf right over your heart detection really good for you
but you don't want it to interfere with the type of device long question we know that cancer uses
glucose to feed itself yes it does very often and if that is totally cut off we understand it could
switch to glutamate let's make sure we understand this um cancer can be feeded off of glutamate
glutamate in the thiety which are amino acids right from the get go and are not feed really
off of glucose at all so uh that's why we test for it so but if we block the cancer from using
glutamate let's just say one few fuel source it seems that it can use another pathway maybe fatty
acids it can use fatty acids but usually doesn't because it takes so long to break down fatty acids
to become a fuel source so because of cancer's high metabolic rate it typically will not use fatty
acids um but it can so that's why we test for that and sometimes we're testing for this particular
foods and let's say pork comes up and red meat comes up well it's quite possible that it's actually
the fatty acids in pork and red meat it's not so much the glutamated metiety that is
all together possible because we're testing the food test kit not the specific that will be treated so
that is my positive so if so how would we know to stop this process that's where you just get
another cheek swab and make sure you check out there that we checked from diet so that we're make sure
we are seeing weight loss that looks to be quite unhealthy we don't want that so make sure we check
I don't know who asked this question but whoever it is um maybe she just scheduled a call with me
or you could send it to the cheek swab now we're we're putting on the cheek swab for make sure you
are no eat that other cheek swab for you're sending the cheek swab to our new address so if you have
to jot this down make sure you are setting it to our new address this is our warehouse actually
this is the fastest way to get it to me and uh so that's our new address so make sure it comes to this
address it's out of all of our stuff though the other back office that you're gonna be so those
have just joined us we're gonna have to do cancer membership site for all our patients up
right next week and um you're gonna get an email from us saying hey you're you doesn't get an email
in a today from our site at that hum spot that will give you access to the new membership site
then you just have to use that email that we're sending to that's your made email use that email as
your user name don't try to use a different email because you won't be allowed in that's how the
membership site works and that's how you keep patients out of it um and the new curator
uh and then you'll have access to our new membership site which has a whole bunch of information
that is a data website and it has all our zoom cuts that's how you'll be able to get our zoom calls
this recording will be up in that tomorrow and also um all our all our past so we're gonna go to
and then we have some questions so all right let's open it up for questions we already had some
clear that exact you know goodness yes that's your how i can how can i diagnose shingles and how can i
treat it at home without the use of data balance we have a shingles protocol so make sure you contact
your liaison and we can get the shingles protocol of two um it works works pretty good it's not perfect
um but about 70% of that time it really drops the the symptoms down to you know really fast so
shingles protocol i've used for decades with people so next what is the best method to read THC
run by system i currently use it for peat and sleep um it's it's it's basically the whole
adage delusion is the solution to collusion so in this case THC will reconsider the pollution
if you just have to remove it so water uh supporting your liver coffee in the uh
castoral packs over your liver just hop back over your liver go back and download
that seven phases of detox book to help you understand that make sure you're having the
problem let's make sure you're using some biders to grab onto it it uh got so that you get rid of it
out of the system you don't re-absorb it um make sure you're not constipated um so those would be the
key things to do to get rid of this next question if we massage the castoral alchac on the liver
kidney and gall bladder before using the sona can the heat cause detox of these organs and
we beneficial i think the question is if you use the castoral pack on your liver and gall bladder it's
such and then you go and uh can you do it in the sauna is it or before you do the sauna
honestly i think you could do it you could do it in the sauna you could go castoral pack on your
liver um in the sauna you could do it uh before you do it in the sauna absolutely that's the whole
idea the castoral pack as you're using heat so go back and look at the castoral pack information
that your binder or looking on the on the website again you can search for it right there um but um
the search for castoral packs in the idea the castoral will pack protocols you're putting heat
over the castoral pack um what is the evidence for using any of the CBD or THC to treat cancer
well boy there's um there's a lot of evidence that's coming out there's more and more studies coming
out so it suggests you just do a google scholar search um that um most of it's going to be um based upon
using it to help with symptoms of um of colleges use of chemotherapy um but there's a lot of
articles if you search for them and use them as far as you see like rick simpson oil to treat cancer
you're not going to find really you're i don't know how many articles are going to find out that
because uh it's i just doubt that there has been any studies that have that got through by
the two two so i've done it for the five days studies on that so that evidence is all animal
that i don't believe that there are a lot of things you'll read about anything with cancer is that
this cures cancer every time it goes through of course that's just not a sense of evidence so um but
that's why we test for it because it doesn't work with everything okay what's the difference between
the five daytime right frequencies in my folder oh it's just for ease of use so there's five shorter
ones in this person's folder i didn't create five shorter ones for everybody but in this case i did
um just for ease of use because typically if people do not have any shorter programs in their program
uh in their folder that i tell them you're going to use it during the day just run that night program
again um just just for ease of use i would cycle through those if i created five of them then they're
different uh slightly different so just use just cycle through them as best you can remember there's no
there's no sequence no so don't worry about that so boy i ran the rife today too i did the first daytime
program oh i can't remember what i did yesterday it doesn't make any difference just run one of them
try to keep your sequence and so that's all the questions so any other questions can you discuss
the grounding difference in your philosophy versus like it's philosophy so the grounding pads
that are out there uh the grounding pad that came with your rife is um uh
is uh uh it's for the ayant roller so i got to pull up a grounding sheet and put that up on the
screen so that up here put up the picture so a grounding sheet is something i think this person
is talking about so this is our grounding uh let's see uh the grounding or earthy sheet that we sell
now it looks like that so it is um a clock material that you would put on the lower half of your bed
across this would fit across a king bed the lower half i mean from your bucktocks down to your feet
and then you'd put the fitted sheet over the top of it so you would be able to stay in
place and then you plug it to with this little plug thing you plug it to that little thing and
then you put this either in the ground of the rife machine because that goes back to the ground
or you could plug it into the ground of an outlet the bottom of the of a three-prong outlet so
your outlet of the wall has two uh prongs on the top that's positive and negative in the
round dip prong on the bottom that's the ground this little yellow thing is simply a ground
tester to see if your own bits are actually grounded because if it's not grounded then this thing's
not going to do anything and the reason why that we include that in there is because often people
actually have a three-prong outlet in their wall so they think they have grounded outlets
but the electrician who connected it never actually connected it to the ground
which is really unfortunate and it had multiple patients and it's happened to have paid lots of
money to have their house really wide and it would be efficient just in a shoddy job so if it was
properly inspected by an electrical inspector they would probably contact so um
but that is how you use a grounded sheet now i know there's philosophies out there and i think
like it's the right place if you should use everybody should use a grounded sheet and you should use
it on your whole bed but understand your right frequencies are going to be attractive to the ground
to this grounded sheet so if you are using a grounded sheet and you have it on your whole bed and you
have your bulb on your telly and you're laying on your back well there's no harm no power because
those frequencies are going right to you to the ground but even at that think about we want these
frequencies to go through at your whole body not just mainly through your chest to the ground we want
them to go up to your head we want them to go out of your feet um so if you have a ground that's on
the full side of the bed and you roll over to the side and the bulb falls right next to your sheet
but maybe it's even still touching your body you're going to lose a lot of those frequencies
right to the ground right to the grounded sheet back through that wire back to the
into the electrical system into the grounded rod into the ground so um if you use a grounded sheet
this is my philosophy you only use it on the lower half of your bed use it on the lower half of the
bed usually you're going to be just fine unless you are um putting the your bulb weight out low
on your body and it's weighed out by your feet or something like that but I'm hopefully everybody's
listening to my instruction and you're kind of struggling with that bulb up at your chest all the
time and it might fall down by your side when it's not falling down by your leg so if you use a
grounded sheet I think you should use the grounded sheet only on the lower half of your body you're
still getting the benefits of the grounded but you're not losing the frequencies so the benefits of
the grounded are immense I would tell people to read the book everything um that could help you
understand um that you know we pick up we are basically antennas and we pick up different
charges you're picking up a positive charge all the time and I don't mean positive by good if it's
a positive charge and then you have to disperse that charge and the best way you do it is you go walk
around in the grass with your bare feet and you're going to disperse that charge and you'll pick up
electrodes from the earth that's the benefit of pets that's the benefit of horseback riding
horse or you know dog is running around roving itself on the earth all day long if you let it
outside horse is standing on the ground grouting itself it's a great conductor of electricity that's why
horse therapy is so good for autistic kids for abused people for alcohol addiction people
it could just settle your braid down it's all has to do with grounded um so it's
horse horses are nice too so um they're just like giant dogs so um but that's what Earth
thing or using a grounded sheet can do for you you could actually use these grounded sheets on your
chair let's say your desk chair that you sit it all day I used to have one plugged in by chair before
moved um and you have it plugged into the wall so you're basically growing yourself
so it's very beneficial oh there you go it's questions I wrapped the rife lamp with a
dark fabric and put it under the top sheet next to the bed I am still getting the results yep you are
so you could put the your rife your rife machine won't penetrate putting a tube sock on it for
something like that to keep you from being blinded by the light at night um it won't penetrate your
body it's not going to do any good you're too right this should penetrate that just fine what's
the difference between natural sweeters are some more harmful than others I get conflicted into info
how does sugar in fruit affect cancer how does monk fruit desilator stevia affect cancer
yeah it is very confusing so when we test four things we test that sugar is even a
they driver in your cancer it is then we tell you that um well if sugar isn't the driver in your
cancer um rife is monk fruit is that no then these won't be either um if sugar is a driver
your cancer can you use monk fruit well it still is sugar so you still have to be careful with how
much you use of that is dilatol the driver your cancer if sugar is no dilatol is not sugar so it's
completely different um that's a type of sugar alcohol um and is stevia a driver of your cancer no steve
is not a driver of your cancer you'd never see that to do it so um it's it's hard to know okay well
how do i know what should i should we do it no other way because there's so much information i think
the bottom line is it's just try to use condensates in that you're not doing simply one thing
all the time so you're doing a mixture of different things can be very beneficial it's like
it's like the old edits that they used to say for years is that um we were really created to eat
in season it doesn't make any sense to me that we could eat apples every single day of our life um
that's that the way god made it think think of how god made things to come in season yes we're
supposed to be able to to pick apples and put them in cold storage so that we could maybe
stretch out that season to maybe six months instead of only two months um but
to that we could get stuff from another part of the world that is now that's in season for those
people and we can keep eating them think about that maybe it's not really not good for us maybe
we should have this rotational diet or we're not eating the same thing all the time so even with
things like that i think that's why you get conflicting data of things like this
is this as monk monk fruit is good for you you should eat monk fruit as your sugar substitute
um but then you get data that says a little monk fruit isn't good for you well i think
it's because it's not good for you all the time and so having mixing things up can be very
beneficial i think there's just a lot of wisdom get that so that you're you're doing more of a rotational
diet you don't have to follow like the eating in season we're all normally apples wouldn't be in season
here so i'm not going to eat them until they come into the season but just rotate it you're not
eating them all the time i mean some people get it to have it or they're eating but it is every
single day maybe that says it's a good idea i don't know i'm just saying just think about it
what happens if you do not use the ground bean sheet when the rice the sheet is ready
used the ground bean sheet whether right the sheets are i don't use the ground bean sheet at all
so understand on my bed i don't have a ground bean sheet so and that's why we don't push
selling the ground bean sheet so um we have them you can buy them from us um but we don't ever push
them you never hear us talking about error but you need a ground bean sheet because i don't think
everybody should get a ground bean sheet because i think there could be this use of it and you could
lose a lot of the frequencies that rather have you get the frequencies while you're sleeping
getting grounded you can grow yourself during the day does the more color and sediments
indicate effectiveness for the food footbat um the answer is you maybe um so i'm that i've never been
a big fan of saying oh wow look at the drought in the water it must be coming out of my liver
or anything like that i know there's charts on that you can google them i just don't think
they're accurate i just don't believe that fully and you're not doing the footbat necessarily to
pull this gun body you're doing the footbat to run different frequencies that can be beneficial
if yes it may pull some gun body you too so don't be hung up on that do metal coils in your mattress
interfere with the right machine no they don't interfere with the right machine at all um i can't
interfere with some things i suppose i mean some people that are highly sensitive to electromagnetic
radiation if they feel maybe that could be positive i don't know um i think different people have
different sensitivities that they do need to address different things like that um some of the new
mattresses like those purple mattresses and those memory foam mattresses i think there's maybe
you've got to look at the dangers of how those are made i know there's one company that's not the
purple company that makes it all natural not a toxic i don't know what they use it it i don't know
dollar and it's not that she's really like that but you got to look at the toxic things being
mattresses and stuff too i think that's even more of a danger the different fire retardants that
our uh government has forced companies to use in things like that are highly toxic cancer-causing
things in themselves uh and you have to be careful of those as well should i take the luval's solution
two percent by and out to help with my cancer um if you haven't got your binder back um
you all will see if that tested or not you can't really hurt yourself with luval's except i take
uh you can by taking too much of it personally i'm not a fan of luval's solution i'm more of a fan
of the kelp-based iodides if you're going to use iodide i'm more of a fan of kelp-based iodide
because it's more of a whole food-based iodide because it's a better iodine solution
with potassium iodide so um but um typically um take it iodide there's really got a lot of
negatives so if you have that then you take you know low doses of it you know standard dose of it
that's listed on the bottle i don't see any problem what type of program is that use a different
valve what type of cold is it use a different valve and a grounding mat oh are there types of
programs that use a different valve and a grounding mat so if you look at the program in the right
it'll show pictures of a person using a different valve and using a grounding mat maybe
and even say that's what you should do and there's some applications that that makes sense okay so
i'm just going to do the right of my tooth maybe i want to put a grounding mat on my upper back so
the frequencies are going more directly right to the ground lead mat so you can think of it that way
the grounding mat is going to attract the frequencies so the draw line between the valve and the
grounding mat that's going to be the general direction of the frequencies not all the current but the
general direction. So strategic use of a grounding mat can be beneficial i guess so if you think of it
that way you can you can understand that should you use a different valve well the hammer valve is
one of the strongest valves there's the double bubble with the screen back that's a little bit
stronger certainly can't use that at night if it is stronger especially if you touch it to your skin
so there's there i mean we have multiple valves that they're quite accurate but honestly most
time for this using the hammer valve we at home i only have the hammer valve so don't need to
understand love mike it's the right but he isn't the business assembly thing so you don't need to
get the numbers over there. Can you use those program programs even the development you have or
don't worry about yes yes yes yes yes so for those of you that are new to this call you're also new
to the right so when you start using your right you want to make it it's i again i've told everybody it's
not a fantasy of all disease but it should be your first go-to thing for everything so all my
child's got an earring run the ear infection programs all my daughter's got a little sore throat
run the strap programs on her some of them are short some of them are maybe an hour or two long
as long as they'll sit there run the program use that for your first go-to think of it as your
medicine cabinet that you should use as your first go-to on everything so um tonight that fix the
problem but certainly it's gonna help especially if you'll you'll have other things like nutrition
and things too as well you don't be afraid to use the right you cannot overuse it you'll never
burn out your ball you're not going to have a crack or something i told you by
two raves of home what is now probably go to three years old and one is try to be in bed over
years old so i don't have a crack or anything because it's constantly the only question
can you use the right on anybody anyways yes you can use it on a little baby you can use it on a
guess who could use it on everybody two logs don't bake all right
it's quality there all right with that i think we'll be to do thank you guys for being on
tonight again you could email your questions in and soon we'll see at the membership page
you could do it right now. All right, we prayed for everybody. I asked the two guys to
pray for us, pray for protection, pray for just health and safety. We're really
praying for you. Oh, let's forget. Please, please, please, if you have it done this,
can you guys please email us a picture? Um, could be you, could be your family, but it's
kind of you in there. So okay, so don't just send us a picture you don't. So
set us a picture because we're putting up a brand new big giant magnetic prayer mord
in our office and I want to get everybody's picture up there for our prayer mord.
So please email it to info at colorsplidic.info at colorsplidic. I will get it in
pretty quickly. We'll get it up as a prayer. Thank you, fans. Love you all.